syrian kurds live on one side of this
border
turkish kurds on the other
in the small town of jaylon pina
for decades the region has been peaceful
but now civil war is raging on the
syrian side and the violence is spilling
over
the windows of this cafe were shattered
by a grenade fired by islamist militias
it's kurdish owners the algarchs want to
give it up
they come from chechnya from afghanistan
serbia and who knows where else
the kurds on the other side have a right
to defend themselves
for weeks the militant islamists of the
al-nusra front have been battling
syria's ethnic kurdish minority with the
turkish side occasionally caught in the
crossfire
the algarchs have done what they can to
repair the damage
we've been living in fear for months
we could be hit again at any time
these groups aren't far from here we
know that for sure
the kurds in jaylon pina say the turkish
army only strikes back when assad's
forces violate the border
they've never fired a single shot
against the islamist militias
even though the damage they've wrought
in the town is plain to see
trains haven't been stopping in jay
lampina for months because of the
constant exchange of fire
five people have been killed in jay
lampina alone
many in the town are convinced that
turkey is actively supporting the
islamists in their campaign against
syria's kurds who want an autonomous
state
ankara which this year agreed to embark
on a peace process with the banned
kurdistan workers party or pkk
now fears the situation will fuel the
aspirations of its own kurds for
self-rule
with its withdrawal from turkey the pkk
took the first steps
but the government hasn't done anything
yet
what's even worse is that it's getting
involved with the kurds in syria
but we could stick together if any of us
are under attack we all feel it
personally i have dozens of relatives in
syria
so what's going on there has major
repercussions for the peace process
between turks and kurds
the turkish government rejects any
suggestion that it has ties to islamist
militias in syria
but three weeks ago footage was shot of
fighters who could belong to the
militias taking delivery of army boots
from turkey at an official border
crossing
they didn't like the fact they were
being filmed
another photograph shows a politician
with the government's ruling akp party
talking to an al-nusra fighter
this resident of jail ampina says it's
evidence that the turkish state is
behind the attacks on kurds on the other
side of the border
he wants to remain anonymous because he
fears for his son's life
like many other turkish kurds his son
has gone to syria to join the fight
against the islamist militias
he was injured a month ago but he
recovered
it's been days since i heard anything
from him
the fighting continues
initially after the start of the civil
war in syria our kurdish brothers were
unaffected
but then what does turkey do
it supplies the islamists with weapons
why to fight assad no to destroy the
kurds
the first turkish kurds to have died in
the conflict are being buried
the funeral of a 28 year old was held
recently in a suburb of istanbul
he died fighting the illness for a front
in syrian kurdistan
his friends swore they would avenge him
our friend went there to support them in
their fight
if groups such as al-nusra continue to
attack the kurdish people then many more
people will go there to fight not just
from turkey
the shops in jae lumpina shut as soon as
it gets dark
what with fighting on the other side of
the border few people venture onto the
streets after nightfall
everyone's worried about their children
and the grenades that rain down on the
town every night
the children are sleeping badly and wake
up at the slightest sound
whenever we hear the sound of bombs the
kids come into our bed
i've stopped going to school every day
a lot of the teachers have moved away
because they're afraid
these days the children of jae lumpina
are sleeping on the floor where it's
supposedly safer
the town they live in is at war